you
you
robots it seems will soon be capable of
doing anything are there any limits to
where they can be deployed
what will be left for humans to do when
machines can perform the tasks just as
well if not better and what will happen
if and when artificial intelligence
become superior to our own
this Rose gets for you have a
what we are experiencing is a revolution
silently and without resistance a
revolution that was given a name by
three experts at an industrial trade
fair in Hanover in 2011 industry 4.0
originally it was 3.0 but then we did a
recount and agreed on four historically
speaking there had already been a third
Industrial Revolution the gaps are on
mr. rush against the way we did it
turned out better sixteen people
the term led to a political debate and
parnell borealis internet dating live in
sukhasana Henning carga man was CEO of
sa P the largest software company in
Europe before being appointed president
of Germany's National Academy of Science
and Engineering
carga man is considered an influential
lobbyist his partner the Ministry of
Education and Research is volge dieter
Lucas who is responsible for everything
connected to industry 4.0 artificial
intelligence expert Wolfgang Vaz de was
also involved in coining the term the
observable compute we're trying to
create computers with we like to say
ears hands and feet and some ability to
reason so the factory of the future is
obviously part of that if I pick that so
confident you are going to witness the
demonstration of the world's first
automated kitchen and today the abyss
invited us gebisa fish Co today we can
already build systems that perform
certain skills based on pure cognitive
intelligence like driving a car that
work better and with greater precision
than humans dementia delve in by the
sensory perceptions of humans also have
deficits take the sense of smell we can
deploy artificial noses as sensors in a
food production factory for example that
have a superior sense of smell to ours
Thermage
the robot is programmed to cook for up
to four people and that means that it
was four identical plates they will look
exactly the same and also taste the same
man or machine people still feel a
little perturbed when robots get up
close and personal but the relationship
between humans and machines is changing
in the future robots will be a
commonplace integral part of our lives
that at least is the future envisage by
industry 4.0 goon valve are these a big
lift in at some point the term industry
4.0 was used to describe a not yet
clearly defined approach what we try to
do was put meat on the bones for
business consultant dormouse grin the
term has become the brand of a
promotional campaign what is industry
4.0 it's the fourth Industrial
Revolution
it means Brynn urges his audiences to
join the revolution of being integrated
they don't want to belong to the loser's
new Venus and knew losers out there in
the city of Ur acid Roland Berger
Strategy Consultants industry 4.0 means
companies should modernize factories or
build new ones separate the wheat from
the chaff those who hesitate will
eventually be left behind in Vancouver
would be meager Hong Kong's way Colombia
don't go far what does make sense and
what is the consultant also asks what
now needs to be done on the
digitalization front he encourages
businesses to upgrade their factories
for the future and to train their staff
for the new tasks at hand or recruit new
staff the danger he says is waiting
until they have no choice but to
implement industry 4.0 there's no time
to waste to get started
the term industrialization refers to
technical and social change
in the early and mid 19th century
neighboring towns across Europe joined
up to form industrial hubs the power of
steam and water was harnessed to power
machines that in turn manufactured
consumer goods coal and the production
of steel and iron in enormous factories
were the building blocks of the first
Industrial Revolution
electricity raised industrial production
to a new level as the number of
factories grew so did gainful employment
and the labor market the Second
Industrial Revolution assured in
assembly lines and mass production the
introduction of computers for data
processing in the 1980s saw the advent
of the third Industrial Revolution now
the position of human workers as a
production factor was coming under
increasing scrutiny
and we are now apparently about to enter
a new era the fourth Industrial
Revolution ah as I tell this one thing I
know about come join bar and Kevin is
cinemates fire in a singe industry 4.0
is gaining traction in Asia people there
are hugely interested in what's
happening in Europe and whether Europe
has really regained the lead in this
area due to the technological upheavals
taking place CIO shop tries to meet you
thank you much
this delegation represents a Chinese
company that could become a major
customer for vibe Miller a German
manufacturer of electrical connection
technology kunda I know they're goostin
proper [ __ ] endeavor this client is one
of the biggest manufacturers in the
world
with far in excess of a million
employees in China they have a large
number of factories not just in China
when deploying robots on that kind of
scale it's vital that you maximize and
realize your potential productivity's
and efficiencies and that's our job is a
simple example high-rise buildings have
elevators which have to be serviced at
regular intervals let's say every three
or six months and whether they used once
a month or thousands of times all
elevators are subject to that monitoring
interval it is above a house interval
with industry 4.0 those 3,000 people who
performed that service might become just
100 Baba hopefully the elevator or
components in the elevator would contact
a data analysis Center when it needs
servicing Oh Seattle found out in signal
is it has all fitted to completely
disrupted concept in terms of technical
maintenance is 44 and odds
Buster's team our battle between and
displacing established factors is what
the guests from China are interested in
their company
Foxconn currently has 400,000 workers
assembling mobile phones in China except
the management has announced plans to
replace three quarters of
with robots every year the Swiss resort
of Davos hosts the World Economic Forum
on the agenda for the first time in
January 2016 was automation and the
likely prospect of five million jobs
disappearing around the globe over the
next four years alone
this year's World Economic Forum in
Davos centers on a revolution from above
the fourth Industrial Revolution for
industry 4.0 two and a half thousand
business leaders scientists and
politicians are discussing the
deployment of robots digitalization and
the networking of machines artificial
intelligence and the Internet of Things
the founder of the event Klaus Schwab
calls it possibly the greatest challenge
facing the world industry 4.0 an
Industrial Revolution the question is
who will be the winners and who will be
the losers of this revolution I'm bill
this revolution is also being felt in
the banking and investment center of
Manhattan in accordance with Microsoft
founder Bill Gates old quote that we
need banking but not banks young
companies are providing new solutions by
the internet threatening to replace
established financial services providers
you
an internal survey conducted by the New
York office of Deutsche Bank on Wall
Street predicts a crisis of
unprecedented proportions on the labor
market for the first time new technical
developments are set to destroy more
jobs than they create fewer and fewer
workers will be needed for the same
output a change with far-reaching
consequences for industry and society
the internal labor market analysis is at
odds with upbeat forecasts for industry
4.0 is this the reason Deutsche Bank in
New York declines to comment the
silhouette of a worker with tool a work
of art in Frankfurt's financial district
symbolizing the world of labor among the
subjects being discussed in the offices
towering above the figure is which jobs
will no longer exist in the future at
ING deburr the German subsidiary of a
Dutch financial group economists
ingerborg and Carsten Bosch etske
are working on that very issue they've
been looking into the consequences of
digitalization for the German labor
market often boutiques I've been looking
at libraries here we have a probability
of 97 percent if we approve of it
frankly that would mean a very large
number of professions potentially
disappearing in the case of unskilled or
semi-skilled jobs such as forklift
operators or postal workers we see a
probability of 89% shine for jobs in
inventory ninety-eight percent so that's
a lot of jobs gone what's in a van a zoo
there Philip Wolfe avec fine Alexander
song with an island from seaport sent
our laptops
put in Sega fairly our research shows 59
percent of all jobs could potentially be
endangered how I do so I guess escaped
at all so the first message is a huge
number of jobs could be lost in the near
future
with an unshakeable essence interest
many of them are jobs with low
qualifications and unskilled works about
but not all so let's get October it
could also mean technically skilled
personnel also gradually losing their
jobs to automation
d-daddy all in our spots re-encode
now as Howser does in schizont or if
you're actively in total around 18
million jobs in Germany are potentially
at risk from automation and
digitalization we are mum of eager
Tiffin for trade gap we've experienced
repeated technical advances in to say
generally didn't cost as many jobs the
survey shows that we're now also looking
at computers to take over number
crunching and replace highly qualified
workers rooster that's a pretty bleak
outlook and a warning that industry 4.0
will not only bring benefits the
securities brokers in the trading area
of Commerce Bank could likewise face the
prospect of being replaced by automated
processes once algorithms are able to
make autonomous decisions on the buying
and selling of financial products
Villa winter named sin Toyota - langsam
a lot of companies today are too slow to
implement industry 4.0 the course not
eight corporations are doing a
relatively good job but smaller firms
are struggling waiting for someone to
come and help them and personally I find
that approach all wrong
companies are architects of their own
fortunes and that requires them to take
action as hours innocency on the steam
Okuma the management consultant is
paying a visit to a company that has
already undergone realignment if Dinka
Canada does kind in general sooner or
later
manufacturers will have no option but
industry 4.0 I assume there is still a
degree of timidity at the moment but
it's a lot of firms have yet to settle
on the area they can concentrate on
those Kasota martinez is constantly
income we have national intend also for
even prior to industry 4.0 work that
could be automated has been automated so
more and more manual production
processes will become redundant albeit
further in portal thorns the trend is
being accelerated by industry 4.0
industry vehicle moobus Lyman
b-bye-bye coalescing SI @ t fo it's an
area we're very active in eventually we
will connect our products directly to
the energy exchange where electricity
prices are set so that we can plan peak
and off peak capacity times depending on
the price of electricity that will give
vibrant of the maximum benefit and
maximum advantage benefits to maximize
photography vital arrows hongcun in the
future
machines would decide themselves when to
increase production for example when the
price of electricity is less expensive
Veidt Muller specializes in industrial
connectivity electronic systems that
coordinate the use of robots in
automated production facilities
my Navy c14 onto the factory my vision
is for our production sites to be
interlinked in a global network and with
our customers and our suppliers ideally
we would have an autonomous smart and
self-regulating system so when a
customer places an order up at the front
the machine will move itself around the
entire delivery chain and at the end the
customer gets their individualized
product dc-8 adulthood in corded model
magazine Oh a new startup in Munich
developed self-controlled systems the
company is working on the world's first
independent minded and operating
warehouse it has received funding from
corporations that are hoping to profit
from advancements in the future the
month Center Theatre Siemens is
interested in robots that can solve
complex tasks in hazardous environments
one example might be robots that could
retrieve objects off the shelves in a
warehouse but if I guess with the title
the question is whether it can reach
over the book and then pick out another
book you might also want it to do the
same thing with boxes as if you're bound
in hot water
yeah we build robots that can react like
humans the robot moves from shelf to
shelf it can see for itself what objects
are there and then it selects them what
an Oscar and that is the robot of the
future is that water table water until
now robots and car production are
example have performed the same weld at
the same spot over and over again
quickly and with perfect precision but
if the car was suddenly the other way
around the robots will be stein it wants
advice but now let's take teddy bears
for example they always look a bit
different or they may have fallen on
their back there's no bar code no RFID
tag the nice thing is when you teach
robots how to pick up the correct teddy
bear they can then share that
information with other
box innovation continue to graph another
victory is a modest of about the robot
also has to be able to work with humans
in the same environment not doing the
same task at the same time might be able
to share the same room with humans
homeless Lagunitas mention of tonkin
java skipping off lighter things will
continue to advance we're doing what is
currently possible but we don't yet know
what will be possible tomorrow I look at
how much we can detect with cameras we
started with books now we're picking up
teddy bears and reaching into shoe boxes
definite sky from attentive and
conveying visual packing there's going
to be a whole range of advances
better efficiency better picker arms
better computer vision algorithms image
recognition possibilities are endless
I don't know mija yeah
the potential of digitalization for
goods distribution and transportation
can already be seen at the port of
Hamburg everyone's Bedoya this des VRT
moogly using the options available with
data processing means that we can now
automatically manage transportation
processes that used to be done manually
autumn artists or vagrants Austrian we
have introduced automation to a degree
not previously seen in container
handling these are Tifa nice gig in mud
semaj Bill Hamid in transport for
example we now have automatic vehicles
transporting cargo from the container
crane to the warehouse yet flats all
those vehicles can ship containers up to
30 tons in weight and they are able to
operate in all conditions as a
vegetation so rainstorms and fog never a
bad person I believe that 20 years from
now we will still have containers but
handling debt will be more effective I
place two of automation
Aldo model we've had an open air
transport which aft indeed a shipping
sector will become more like it is with
commercial airlines now customers
perform all manner of tasks themselves
such as checking in seat assignment and
attaching the cargo label to their
luggage it's ours
Eclipse there was an epic there will be
seeing this second stage in the
transportation sector as well underpants
pod vert raft 11 the alt inverter
container terminal is among the most
technologically advanced in the world in
future containers at other ports will
also find their destinations on their
own
mr. Schiff dick the steamer in this I am
following industry 4.0 or rather labor
4.0 very closely because we can't
achieve anything without the companies
and people affected mentioned you beat
offenses and erosion is happening miss
you can plan advice I don't have a plan
and I don't know exactly how things will
go from here so we initiated an
intensive dialogue raising questions
before assuming the answers you see at
the same time companies also bear
responsibility so I expect it's going to
be a rocky road we need to find a way of
consolidating these new forms of labour
that benefits not only company profits
but also employees employees is no
longer the right term for staff at crowd
guru as the first part of the name
suggests they are deployed on mass and
are themselves called crowd workers the
business model involves earning money by
selling information and data from the
internet data research by tens of
thousands of individuals and then supply
to crowd guru yeah sucker from those
each thousand so I'll go down to Wars
who using then loiter we have around
35,000 gurus as we call them leading
they take care of minor tasks by our
platform and work wherever and whenever
and how much they want and the arbeiten
refused your baton once enough they can
choose which jobs they want to work on
unnhhh in one vacancy but Abidin these
workers would otherwise have a hard time
surviving on the traditional labor
market their tasks here range from
gathering addresses and corporate data
to writing product descriptions and
price comparisons there are several
hundred thousand crowd workers in
Germany alone
Social Security insurance or a minimum
wage do not apply if his alternate magic
hope does horse western Afghanistan we
tried to work out their hourly rate
identity cards if they were to do a
certain job for one whole hour getaway
joke 9 or 12 euros or more it's
verifiable them yeah who's the myth
remembers our biggest competition is
technological evolution being India
there are some things we still do with
the crowd of things where you still need
people to make decisions with image
recognition for example our people can
categorize and tag particular pictures
of abilities and people given technology
is our biggest competition as it evolves
eventually there'll be an algorithm that
can manage these tasks on its own line a
leading come industry 4.0 has various
names from country to country in France
it's known as Lander speed of hoot or
industry of the future in case your
feeders are figures it poses a
philosophical question is humankind in
the process of creating something that
will outlive us or something that we can
live with in relative harmony in
continued Aviva a bernetta users Paul
Jerome anthropologist and economists has
been following the digitalization of
industry for decades le pieu Kumar et
cetera when I was researching artificial
intelligence in the late 1980s and early
90s there were still a lot of obstacles
if it is of the factors that appeared
irresolvable
couldn't prove your path today those
limits of all but disappeared with the
singular death Kong limo with a residue
in the petite Appetit Willy's of sucker
on fitori and wait till they do go they
say it's going to be a very long time
before we see machines replacing humans
I'm at a stage called singularity but in
fact their advances being made on a
daily basis as we move in that direction
yeah now led the politics of it he's
unfit to lead rule the significant on
totally teri
machines will soon be better than us
that might not be the case in all areas
today
thought with things moving forward very
quickly but perhaps it will be tomorrow
has
we tread up in MO but remember
the u.s. west coast has become a hive
for young entrepreneurs many of them are
originally from Europe and they all want
to change the world with computer
programs Noctem Changa combin when my
friends and family asked me how I was
doing after I got here my initial
response was gassed and I feel at home
this Fujisan adds up to [ __ ] anger
combin screw come da hired us it was
mainly because of the sheer number of
like-minded people here all of them with
one goal the Irish people wants to
change the world and set up successful
enterprises on some mention of other
people come here from all over them
geister and the spirit they all share or
gave rise to compass them kompis
implicit compass is an software product
compass is a software product that
replaces in-house analysts McCandlish a
missile for think of the software as an
automated corporate doctor the software
is jump it is to analyze the entire data
of the company's doctor washed it and
the unconceived simply about name
compiled a report on the companies
standing in there all strengths and
weaknesses did in they are insight
wasn't an image d that helps the company
when it comes to making important
decisions in France it damnit they moved
where to invest tide and money into the
15 assess M woman M site on get invested
via be Finland some could sebum and fun
we are at the beginning of a major
socio-economic structural change and
companies like ours are now part of that
change these london's but it will lead
to a lot of people losing their jobs or
having to get retrained in order to find
other work em without distinction women
under - listen em on that's on tuition
and fee enlighten the Hoyt so people who
assume that because they've been to
college and have a good education will
have a secure job may see those hopes
dashed awful ancestor on want and daddy
sure so in other words this development
this change will bring good things but
also bad things so one of the most
successful investors involved in Silicon
Valley lives in the rolling hills of
California's wine country we tend to
talk about Industrial Revolution 4.0 and
the simple thing people say is well
robots are going to replace factory
workers jobs and I think to the most
part that's true but the biggest issue
is going to be computers have now gotten
to the point where they're so
intelligent that they will be able to do
a series of jobs what we call white
collar work today what's required is a
totally different education set that's
why I have a little bit of challenge
with quote Industrial Revolution it's
really an economic revolution 4.0
Josh and off is on the board of the
World Economic Forum in Davos the
Revolution he says will not just render
millions of jobs redundant but also a
lot of multinational corporations we're
going to see global companies go away if
you look at the Dow in 1890 whatever
when it was started there were not
thirty I think there were only 18
there's only one left today which is
General Electric all of them went away I
think that if we just look out ten years
from now about a third of the largest
companies in the world today will no
longer be around there was a famous
headline that Jamie Dimon said banking
industry watch out Silicon Valley is
coming to each or lunch and I think you
could take that and put almost any
industry in there and one that I think
you should be particularly concerned
about is the automotive industry I will
tell you that that's probably going to
have as much disruption over the next
decade is any other single industry as
you look at you know people make a joke
about Tesla today don't make a joke
about it what this team of engineers is
doing is pretty important here are the
most modern car factory in the world the
fourth Industrial Revolution is in the
hands of shiny red robot arms some of
them are called Thunderbird or Colossus
names that evoke fantasy world
superheroes
car maker Tesla was initially ignored by
the big car makers and then belittled
the Giants of the industry struggled on
with their outdated business models in
certain high-profile cases resorting to
the manipulation of emissions tests
meanwhile the fully automated Tesla
production facilities in Silicon Valley
were busy building the electric car of
the future but is Silicon Valley with
its new concepts of value creation also
a paradise for people who work there
women in San Francisco lived in San
Francisco you see these gigantic Google
buses pulling up at 7:30 a.m. Wednesday
the demoiselle have 15 or 20 people
waiting at public bus stops and being
picked up by the corporate buses
nobody's talking they're already working
and later they are driven back you see a
lot of downcast faces some very few
happy ones Falabella Cooley Wendy
Sephardim Silicon Valley is the
incubator of talent for the digitalized
economy it could be a better place as
Tim leverage if there were more active
encouragement of skills specific to
humans that machines do not have the
German marketing manager is a member of
the World Economic Forum's Global Agenda
Council on values and moved to San
Francisco in 2003 there's a stark
attendance in valley there's a strong
tendency in the valley and in industry
in general to have everything quantified
and manageable with a minute Rancic
earns the Jesus regime this regime of
constant productivity optimization has
now reached extreme levels the Silicon
Valley going to practice what do you see
in Silicon Valley is a kind of
troubleshooting machine the idea is that
any problem whether social political or
human can be solved if you deploy
technology with maximum effectiveness
God having doubt on what is your
automation and the fourth Industrial
Revolution will
creativity intuition compassion and the
emotional far more important the VIN via
vocalist if we're competing with
automated machines artificial
intelligence robotics and cell where
performance is judged solely on
efficiency and increasing productivity
with all eyes dogs and then we as humans
don't really stand a chance that hum by
dimensional analysis and be awed we will
be outperformed and as various studies
have forecast eventually become
superfluous voice at if we can create
scope within companies for creativity
intuition to our individuality that
would mean a loss of control for the
company's unhealthily firm so I think in
addition to creating human cultures that
suit us better and give us more room for
expression ultimately it would also make
us more successful let's just earn a
foreclosure
Google avidin Google has a full-time
employee interpreting the insights
traditions and rights of the major
religions for it
ding course novella Gordon Uber's that
they think about what Google can learn
from Islam Christianity and Judaism
learn from Islam from cousin Tom Fong so
they're basically a theological
Authority aren't your audience stands
for something
I think it's regarded Islamic we're
living in a phase where everything is
being instrumentalized by the power of
industries the begin cause a painful
transformational process but personally
I hope the end result will be higher
status for Humanities and for art other
dissolution off we couldn't hear the
guys from Norfolk words
NIEM undirected review nobody expects me
I choose a spot for me and my piano
first people are bemused but eventually
some people relax and get into the swing
of things on fine tuning of the dog
thorn be Madame I've been all over
Germany in Europe with the piano I'm
going to play a nice soft track off the
CD it's called first sunlight and loads
Venice Villa for dimension when I play
for people I notice it has an impact one
for them it's a bit of stress relief
thus I think that's the biggest effect I
can have with my music organ kind of
mellow music does it's a pleasant
experience for people and for me to hear
to see that maybe I can make a bit of a
difference
let's sign up I do they it's work that's
a lot of fun
it totally fulfills me makes me
extremely happy look at them they call
themselves digital nomads they've said
farewell to the concept of a
conventional working day okay no hair
tease become a bit of a lead on edge we
come to linux i did you tell our mothers
a digital nomad is a modern migrant
laborer who uses telecommunications
technologies to earn a living
although in contrast to other migrant
laborers we generally decide where we go
and we have our own projects essentially
you take your work with you on your
travels in mattandsarah us here we
notice ourselves how we no longer feel
so compliant with what's happening here
in germany where everything is
determined by work we want to be doing
what makes us happy
look this man see from sits nice yeah
Jesus yeah this year was truly the first
year we were on the road more than we
were here I'm going to Kannamma see
current generation value their freedom
very highly and no longer pursue status
related things like a job title a nice
car and a permanent residence what
matters are the flexibility and self
fulfillment that have only become
possible with the internet oh now you
can earn money bringing your own ideas
to the street without significant fixed
costs that will become a problem for
companies because the good people will
have chosen alternative options under
thatin Bennion and cytosine hand once
you have a distributor then it's time
for the product sample product must
obtain the slogan at the center it's
ready man get omits I take it off and I
earn my money selling on Amazon kitchen
utensils Pet Products observe dog
leashes kitchen tongs spatulas and alike
I run what you could call a digital
general store and car laden with seitan
as a psyphon instead of going to the
office Monday to Friday I can just open
up my notebook where and when I choose
to and that for me is work but at the
same time freedom as well for me some
sois are bites our glide
tied him off right now it was from
Finland and when I was 15 a career
adviser came to our class he told us how
important it was to get good grades and
have a linear career development we were
to be consistent in our decisions with
no gaps in our resume inside on Zion and
kinda looking in Liam's love hub a
little with the goal of becoming
employable for some reason I decided
back then that that wasn't for me
ethnicity misses its startup Diaries
we're fat and dumb we escaped our office
packed up our business and hopped into a
Land Rover with our friend VIN our
mission travel through South America and
meet people who use technology to
redefine work what started as a crazy
idea
leaving our office behind running a
business from the road and meeting
people who were just as crazy as us
suddenly became a reality but the next
six month we're going to cross South
America in lava Sina the Land Rover
Defender which was to be our office
hostile and means of transportation men
get fit
I earn my money from having a company
I'm the founder and CEO as it were we
help other companies to improve their
customer service service to focus on
this peninsula middle I spent eight
months traveling 20,000 kilometers
across South America with my coworker
and another friend we managed our entire
firm from gas stations hostels and cafes
people from dhadkan minutes to me and
I'm doing this data migration for online
casino in Leslie
and it's just a fun thing to do this
environment so this is really to charge
it over and it's best I got a digital
Nomad one of the first things to do when
arriving at a new place is to get an
internet connection
we found Wi-Fi all around in Buenos
Aires though it's a nice feeling to know
you have a connection wherever you are
yes movie star we get an e connection
that's like really super slow edge
internet but we have three dots for the
phone connection this is a scoping call
for data migration and loudspeaker on
Alice must be my Walkman the internet
gives us everything we need whether I'm
in the desert in Peru or here in the
office in Berlin it doesn't really
matter if I'm in a slum in Namibia or
living on Wall Street it's irrelevant
I love it in slum in the media warner
order and the wall street is cathy
erratically I can get the same education
as someone who goes to Harvard or
without having to pay two hundred and
fifty thousand dollars for it most Ivy
League universities post their lectures
online for free
dr. soon every day why this only worked
via Tyco
somebody has to show people who aren't
aware of this especially young people
that this kind of thing is possible
under the advice they get from career
counselors needs an update
you
you